neben der hochspannenden cdu/csu
telenovela hätte man ja beinahe
vergessen dass wir auch noch dieses
andere themen haben hier dings corona
genau
ja aber da wird ja alles gut denn jetzt
ist die pandemie chefinnen sache quasi
seit heute die bundes notbremse sie
kommt also bald demnächst heute erste
lesung im bundestag
ja da können die intensivmediziner noch
so oft alarm schlagen eine gute
notbremse
die braucht halt zeit die beratungen im
bundestag und dann anschließend auch im
bundesrat werden schon zehn bis 14 tage
in anspruch nehmen und man muss ja auch
sehen dass es auch unterschiedliche
meinungen im bundestag gibt eben macht
seine fröhlichkeit an dieser stelle
wirklich sinn
das liegt im auge des betrachters
beziehungsweise des partners
denn auf den intensivstationen gibt es
tatsächlich nur eine meinung man müsste
handeln
idealerweise jetzt irgendwann nächste
oder übernächste woche greift dann die
bundes notbremse ab incidents 100 viel
zu hoher grenzwert sagen epidemiologen
aber was wissen die schon über epidemie
so debattiert unser bundestag also
maßnahmen die in wirklichkeit schon vor
wochen beschlossen wurden nur dass sie
jetzt umgesetzt werden
hoffentlich neu ist tatsächlich bloß die
ausgangssperre ab 21 uhr und über die
wird muss man sagen zurecht gestritten
es geht ja darum dass zum beispiel
partys verhindert werden aber da ist die
ausgangssperre ja ein völlig
ungeeignetes mittel dann brauchen wir
kontrollen im privaten bereich
meinetwegen richtig christian man müsste
berittene polizei in jede partie rein ja
aber frage wie sind denn die leute zu
der party gekommen durch unterirdische
tunnel mit einem flug taxi oder für dich
vielleicht mal anders erklärt und nicht
jeder der seinen drinnen verlässt und in
sogenannte draußen geht macht das um
spazieren zu gehen manche begeben sich
auch nur ins draußen um dann in einem
anderen drinnen freunde zu treffen
deswegen
idee mit der ausgangssperre also
verstehen sie mich bitte nicht falsch
schon allein das wort ausgangssperre ist
eine absolute zumutung in einer freien
gesellschaft auch juristisch umstritten
klar nur einfach genauso weitermachen
geht offenbar auch nicht alle länder die
b17 die britische mutante in den griff
gekriegt haben hatten an irgendeinem
punkt eine ausgangssperre
klar ist extrem schwer zu vermitteln
wenn die menschen diese woche
gleichzeitig lesen dass bei uns über
vier millionen dosen verimpft rumliegen
weil ja meine natürlich ist man da
wütend aber von wütend gehen die zahlen
halt auch nicht runter wir müssen die
mobilität drücken denn die liegt laut eu
berlin schon wieder bei 80 prozent
unseres normalniveaus und ich meine hier
reden was uns schön selbst so eine
ausgangssperre hat doch auch gute seiten
ausgangssperre drastische maßnahme aber
sie verhindert private treffen und damit
das freizeit grauen schlechthin den
spielort mit freunden wir haben alle
schon mitgemacht und so getan als hätten
wir irre spaß endlich nicht mehr ganze
nächte den arsch beim risiko platz
sitzen weil irgendein idiot kamtschatka
erobern muss endlich einem siedler von
catan sagen es interessiert mich einen
scheiß wie viel verschiedenes ärzte hast
denn rausgehen ist jetzt tabu weil die
inzidenz zahlen so baum aus sind nur so
halten wir die pandemie in schach wenn
wir das nicht machen sind wir am ende
alle voll in den arsch geknüppelt aktion
mensch an städte dich nicht
ausgangssperre gegen spieleabende ja
ganz ehrlich im moment würde ich sogar
zu einem spieleabend gehen so am boden
ist man schon hätten damals schon vor
wochen einen richtigen lockdown hinter
uns gebracht inklusive arbeitswelt aber
die wirtschaft wird ja weiter geschont
überwiegend es arbeiten bei weitem nicht
alle zu hause bei deren jobs das möglich
wäre
fakt und auch nach über einem jahr
corona muss man home office scheinbar
immer noch grundsätzlich erklären man
kann auch sagen home office bedeutet die
arbeit wird gemacht aber woanders ach so
wussten sie dass und nächste woche
hubertus heil erklärt das
kaffeemaschinen maschinen sind die
kaffee machen meine eigentlich sehr
komisch dass ich manche chefs
offensichtlich so gegen home office
sperren
wer da einmal auf den geschmack kommt
der will doch gar nicht mehr dass die
doofen angestellten zurück ins büro
kommen denn jetzt hat man als boss die
firma endlich für sich ganz allein und
für hobbys ohne die nervigen mitarbeiter
da kannst du einfach mensch sein auf
spieße konventionen pfeifen und vor
allem die arch kopien machen von denen
die anderen immer so begeistert erzählen
ja jetzt so gut
die beste nachricht für alle die ins
büro kommen müssen arbeitgeber jetzt
endlich regelmäßige schnelltests
mindestens anbieten überfällig
überfällig auch an unseren schulen wo in
den meisten bundesländern jetzt lehrer
und schüler getestet werden als das
endlich meine da kann man ja eigentlich
nichts dagegen haben besonders hier mit
diesen neuen tests wo man nur noch vorne
so ein bisschen rum puppen muss
ernsthaft wer kann was gegen skopje da
was die afd
die kinder sollen sich selbst im gesicht
rumfummeln und dort irgendwelche tests
durchführen
ich halte das für absolut daneben auch
teilweise rechtlich sehr problematisch
dass ungeschultes personal sich an
meinen kindern vergreift was passiert
wenn diese kinder verletzt werden was
passiert mit den seelischen und
psychischen störungen dieser einhergehen
und das liebe kinder passiert wenn man
sich das stäbchen zu tief in die nase
gibt ja leider werden wir die dritte
welle angesichts der aktuellen zahlen
wohl weder weg testen noch weg impfen
können so sieht's aus die
parlamentarische arbeit an der bundes
notbremse zieht sich trotzdem noch bis
weit in die nächste woche dabei zählt
jeder tag heißt es immer wieder
wir schalten malaktion doktor valerie
niehaus intensiv medizinerin in köln von
hier aus wie sehr frustriert sie die ja
die langsamkeit des verfahrens na ja
klar ist das bitter wenn man quasi jeden
tag sos funkt und keinen jux mehr so
richtig
sie dürfen nicht vergessen unser team
hier arbeitet jetzt seit über einem jahr
am limit normal dass sich da beim einen
oder anderen nervlichen
weil man schlicht nicht mehr fassen kann
natürlich wäre es hilfreich gewesen wenn
alle bundesländer einfach von selbst die
notbremse umgesetzt hätten
aber er die anzahl glaubt nicht leicht
sie haben aber erstaunlich viel
verständnis ja weil ich inzwischen
drogen nehme und weil jedes ding zwei
seiten hat
einerseits werden wir bis ende april
6000 co wird intensiv patienten haben
will sagen tempo bei den maßnahmen wäre
gut andererseits passt etwas nicht
mitmachen werden ist eine beschleunigung
des verfahrens diese eile sie zu fehlern
geradezu ein ist auch gar nicht nötig
denn wir haben eine weitere sitzung
suche können den gesetzentwurf
ordentlich beraten
da ist doch viel besser wozu die eile
nächste woche ist doch auch noch eine
sitzungswoche ja total spannend wenn man
sich da mal rein fuchst mich in die
gesetzgebung ja ich habe das in meinen
wöchentlichen drei stunden freizeit mal
gegoogelt wussten sie dass der bundesrat
eventuell gar nicht zustimmen muss wenn
jedenfalls der gesundheitsausschuss
nächsten dienstag eine
beschlussempfehlung abgibt dann wäre die
zweite und dritte lesung am mittwoch das
wiederum aber hätte zur folge dass jetzt
nicht ich erkläre gerade was hätte zur
folge dass die frist vor der zweiten
lesung verkürzt wird wofür aber die
zustimmung von zwei dritteln der
abgeordneten erforderlich ist so und
jetzt findet die beschlussempfehlung am
kommenden mittwoch und die zweite und
dritte lesung am freitag statt das ist
ja eigentlich ganz einfach nicht die
drogen möchte ich auch mal
modellrechnung der uni saarbrücken eine
woche weiter nichts tun gleich 1000
intensivpatienten mehr
ja absolut völlig richtig
deswegen habe ich jetzt beschlossen ab
sofort genau so zu arbeiten wie der
bundestag das zimmer 1 bis zur pfalz
wartet bevor wir da reingehen ganz kurz
erstmal was klären jetzt ist nämlich
eigentlich schon seit zehn minuten die
nachtschicht dran
ich bin spätschicht bin aber schon in
den überstunden wer von euch ist jetzt
hier nachtschicht ich bin der fruehling
von gäste
ok also laut arbeitszeitgesetz darf die
arbeitszeit jeden tag und zwei über
stunden verlängert werden aber nur wenn
innerhalb von sechs monaten oder 24
wochen acht stunden am tag je werktag
dies war keine leute zu einer echten
intensivstation schauspieler zeigten in
einer fiktiven szene was passiert wenn
pflegepersonal arbeitet wie politik was
es in wirklichkeit nie tun würde
sie sahen eine satirische überspitzung
wir bitten um ihr verständnis
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt haye